you know your nails are long
they're pretty long I only get the long
tips does that make anything difficult
in life like calling somebody or wiping
your ass no I'm used to it it's like an
extension of my body so you have to like
do the wrap though right
when you wipe you have to wrap around
like your hand
you can't just like with nails like that
can you demonstrate what that looks like
if I had nails like you I would assume
that I would have to take the toilet
paper and I would wrap my hand so then
you can
mm-hmm but what happens if you wrap it
too tight I don't know you might have a
shitty hand
have you ever had a shitty hair
definitely
at some point in time speak for yourself
everybody in life has had a rough a
rough goal once or twice you had that
single single plot toilet paper that you